Using SQLite makes it easy to delete,
update, and
insert rows,
using highly expressive queries.
One can even add new columns
as you revision your database,
while retaining existing user data.
It's not a surprise that
just about every popular app
makes some use of SQLite in Android.
It's a very powerful and important
component of the Android solution.
Android also provides a huge set of
helper functions to make working with
databases easy, including functions
to automate query building,
display list views, and
even utilize pre-compiled statements.
For more information about databases
in Android, see the instructor notes.
Well that's what you need to know to get
started with data storage on Android.
All of this is documented
if you search for
data storage on developer.android.com.
We'll be working with these storage
APIs to build our sunshine database.